cerca de la mitad de las escuelas en
francia estarán cerradas este jueves los
maestros decidieron hacer oír sus voces
por los diversos cambios en las reglas
escolares para enfrentar la pandemia las
nuevas normativas fueron establecidas
recientemente por el gobierno a medida
que aumentan los contagios de kobe 19
niños debido a la variante omicron más
contagiosa ahora los niños con edad
escolar pueden emplear un autoexamen en
lugar de las pruebas pcr si un compañero
de clases resulta infectado pero los
constantes cambios en las reglas han
saturado a la paciencia de los
profesores que se quejan por no poder
seguir el ritmo danger hemos llegado a
un nivel de exasperación cansancio e ira
las cosas no fueron explicadas las
familias y el personal docente están
dispuestos a hacer lo que se les pide
pero con la condición de saber por qué
pero ahora no tiene sentido porque
cambiaría la estrategia cada tres días
el gobierno defendió sus nuevos
lineamientos diciendo que simplificaría
en el procedimiento de evaluación para
padres y maestros y lo que es más
importante permitirían mantener las
escuelas abiertas su protocolo a esta
nueva estrategia es fácil de entender
significa menos tiempo de espera más
flexible todos mientras ponemos la
seguridad de la salud en primer lugar
elegimos mantener las escuelas abiertas
tomamos la difícil decisión de continuar
trabajando en lugar de la fácil decisión
de cerrar metió para el sindicato que
organizó las manifestaciones el cambio
de estrategia deja vulnerables a los
estudiantes el personal y sus familias
además que amenaza la educación de los
niños a principios de la presente semana
10.000 clases fueron suspendidas en todo
el país debido a los casos de kobe lo
que representa alrededor del 2 por
ciento de todas las aulas de la escuela
primaria